[Music]
christian and i grew up near a water
source called the mill river in
connecticut one summer i got really into
crabbing
i got this crab net and uh
when when it at low tide i went to the
mill river and i caught some uh a bunch
of crap a whole mess of them as mom
would say you got some crabs i got some
crabs uh insert your own joke here well
i don't get the joke well no i don't
know i don't either but i'm saying maybe
people might have a crab joke just about
the animal and so i put him in a bucket
and uh my mother
steamed him up we we ate him that night
i don't know there's this primal feeling
of being like resourceful and like doing
procuring food with your hands you know
like uh and that i had done this i felt
very
accomplished and
a couple weeks later there was an
article big article big story in our
hometown
about how the meal river was being
polluted and was toxic and that under no
circumstances should you eat anything
in the river especially something like a
crab or a monster any shellfish any
shellfish because they're the ones that
filter out all those toxins that's kind
of how they feed right so um yeah
but happy ending you live to talk about
it at this point yeah still alive and
nothing uh that we know of that
caused any long-term effects so you're
right i love happy endings
you're listening to life is short i'm
your host who hates double entendres
justin long
with me as always is my um
equally i love double entendre
you do i love saying double anton i hate
saying that don't you hate saying it's
it's hard to you don't like saying any
french things i know it's just gonna say
that both have to not like saying french
things well because nothing against
french not at all it's a beautiful
language that's the kind of the thing
it's so beautiful that you don't feel
worthy i don't feel worthy and it's also
like it sounds so so there's that it
hasn't that's british now i know i know
i don't know
what's i'm trying to leave another
french word that dublin tom i like to
pronounce shay's lounge chase lounge
because if to pronounce it properly it
sounds in english in our in america in
american in america it's an american
yeah i know you know what i'm saying it
sounds something
name some mustards
dijon dijon
yeah it's the same way we i don't want
to pronounce i know that it's pho is
pronounced
i know that but i just feel like it's
heard saying that why are we talking
about
french people wait sorry i was going to
say about uh french words croissant
remember the other day you shamed me for
swiss songs
what did i say chris chris you really
leaned into the french i did yeah you're
like you you're like
yeah well you made fun of me maybe
that's why i shy away from french
sounding words like dublin it's my fault
why are we talking about because our
guest today isn't french
yeah but but but french
france is has one of the
great cuisines of the world uh speaking
of food and different cuisine our guest
today well is i i would say our mother's
favorite easily right favorite guest
that we've had yeah well except for
grandma jody of course second favorite
second favorite um
our guest is rachel ray the well she
doesn't call herself a chef so i
hesitate to say that so i shouldn't she
is a um but what would you say a cooking
personality um that's been on
you've been in the zeitgeist for a long
time yeah cooking personality doesn't
sound i know it sounds respectful i know
it sounds like belittling she's like a
mogul i would say she's like uh she's an
entrepreneur now that sounds too like
business related but she is she is yeah
but she has a lot of businesses
she but she's also but to me that sounds
kind of like um
eve not like a villain like a like a
businessman would be a
fat right i don't know but she's also a
philanthropic we get into all of it um
you know her i feel like she doesn't
really need an introduction she's one of
those guests we're doing it she has she
has a new show true and we have a show
she has an introduction to the rachel
the rachel ray show that she has been
doing from her home in upstate new york
since the pandemic began um so people
know her from that show but also people
know her from her town that she lives in
probably what it's just that they know
of her right and also she is um
she's a famous chef and she was on the
forefront of the
um
of the fast
that's right movement like the 30-minute
meal yeah movement which was really uh
spearheaded that's a movement that we
really love because um we've been
cooking a lot in over the last year and
we've talked about a bunch and it's so
nice to have those i i understand why
she
became so popular because those meals
are
really popular and good to tell people
about but also like she's a really fun
personality yeah she's bringing cooking
and many other things to the masses yes
and a lot of like you said a lot of
charitable works and you were on her
show many years ago and when you were on
her show
you had our mother on as well yes it was
a huge thrill for wendy and um so that's
why she was yeah and my mother always
talks about me going back what are you
going back on rachel ray and i thought
wow they got a you know there's a
there's a protocol here i can't just
show up on the show right uh so my
mother was yeah she was thrilled that
day she was fun my mom our mom was an
actress and um
and so she's used to being on camera
she's comfortable in that setting but
for some reason when she was on the show
she really liked she was like a giddy
deer in headlights remember that yeah
she absolutely loves rachel ray and has
adopted a lot of her buzzwords that's
right
that's nutrition and delish
she's sounding a lot more like rachel
ray over the years and uh because she
really looks up to her and our mother in
her own right is a brilliant cook so i
don't want to diminish her by any means
but uh she really likes rachel ray and i
think we should all hear from rachel ray
and to so we can better understand why
she likes her so much yeah this will
help you understand wendy our mother um
oh and one thing we should mention
is that uh at some point during this
interview her husband john joins and um
it happened organically but when you
hear another man's voice that's not
yours yeah that's not justin's rather
i'd throw you a little bit know that
that's her husband yes he just kind of
came into the zoom uh sometimes i forget
that people aren't watching this i i had
the experience i thought you were trying
to say he came to the room and
you uh stumbled into accidentally saying
zoom oh but you said he came into the
zoom oh yeah it's weird that's so common
though
killer
[Laughter]
yeah oh my god it came to the zoom you
said it's so casual oh my god
how i was talking today about how much
has changed how much of our behavior has
changed because this pandemic and not in
like a not in like dire ways not in like
you know obviously there's that the life
and death death element golf the tragic
element uh heavier elements but like
just in simple uh similar ways just the
the the way we're handshaking and
interacting but that's another one that
i hadn't considered that are it's
affecting our language
food for thought yeah speaking of food
and thought my ketchup with america's
culinary sweetheart rachel ray life
could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
ah often i have to say especially in the
last year uh it's been a hard one for us
yeah i cried a lot but i don't cry over
injury nor do i was gonna say pain
people that grow up in kitchens don't
cry over injuries we just work through
them yeah
the way you're raised what's what's the
gnarliest one that you that comes to
mind that you had
i have burned off this entire quarter of
my hand i've cut off both of my first
fingers and glued them back on with um
literally crazy blue on this one
wait broken wait both of my pinkies i
broke this thumb
just last week
cheese is all from cooking yeah when
you're in a kitchen
you just you just keep going
i ripped off
uh my my father-in-law was coming here
i'm in the adirondack mountains my
father-in-law was coming here one time
and i was carrying in wood just like
john it was a wood injury yeah but i was
only wearing flip-flops and i tripped
and i hit the stone step in such a way
that my entire
my entire
right
big toe toenail ripped off backwards and
blood hurting straight up
i had to stick my foot
in a bucket of ice no cauterized spoon
with salt
wrap it and continue to roll meatballs
for the family dinner no no are you um
are you in trauma are you go are you uh
is your body are you sweating what's
happening to you physiologically
how do you go on you just do it man
i cry over
what's on the inside
of my head yeah i don't cry over
physical injury like i've been in car
crashes and still went to work that day
i was covered in gasoline flipped my
truck the axle broke on the bottom of my
truck the car flipped so hard
and i had a cheese order coming in
and i called my mother who lived
a few miles away and i i literally had
my mom drive me to work so that i could
check in the cheese order
well that's all the time we have uh
thanks rachel this has been
uh
wow you know what because i i i i'm
still hung up on the um fingers
being crazy glued back on
is that were you being literal you cut
off part of your finger and
i cut off part of my finger on my first
day of food network 22 or so years ago
and my day of the daytime show both
and that's how i knew what to do on the
first day of the daytime show uh i
wasn't even chopping food i was talking
with my hands
and i had a factory sharp santoku uh
chef knife and i was talking with my
hands and i literally uh
cut off the tip of my phone oh just
gesticulating just
just um
yup and so
i flipped it back over
and they tried nu skin it didn't work
and i literally took crazy glue and
crazy glued my finger
and they put a little powder on it and i
make three shows
good
lord uh
and i'm now cute and you got the cheese
back the [ __ ] so it's all about the
the job it's all about the i got to cook
something i have people coming over this
is a toe
it's
it's it's just
you know
my grandfather when i was a little girl
was
uh lived with us and he was my caretaker
he was my best friend when i was really
little yeah
and my grandfather
whenever i would get upset or throw a
fit
he would make fun of me he would laugh
in my face ah literally laugh in my face
until i would stop crying yeah that's
interesting tickle me
and push my hair back and every time i'd
cry more or do the uh
yeah he would literally just get in my
face and laugh
and he taught me when i was very small
that
there are so many things in life that
will bring you real pain
save your tears and when it is your
choice
laugh don't cry
it's uh i love that a great lesson and
i've used it my whole life the first
time i remember that was when i went to
school and he taught me how to read and
he was very proud of it
he came here as the
four of 14
the four youngest came to america wow
and
my grandpa was a stone mason
the main cook for his family and he had
10 children wow my mother was the first
of the 10.
very tough strong smart beautiful human
okay
he was my best friend he would let me
sit on his lap when they played trey
three sevens or sculpa
uh all the italian card games with the
runzo boys
he was very animated
he would read og natalia and he would
recreate
um fake uh
there was no uh you know
cable everything
uh
football games you couldn't watch soccer
you know from from europe in america so
he'd read the paper as if you were
watching it on the television for his
friends oh and re-enact the game and
then just have me uh yeah he was so
animated and he'd say what happened to
each character
and i remember the smell of his pipe and
his flannel shirt sitting on his lap and
and the
he was very proud that he taught himself
to read in english and he read
every book he could get his hands on and
we had a beautiful library of my
grandpa's books
and some of them burned in my house we
lost our home this past year i heard and
it was the biggest heartbreak of my life
is my mom's handwriting and books that
my grandpa
had read to me when i was a girl he was
very proud of
in becoming an american and
and um he really was very proud of
teaching me how to read in english
so when i went to school he made me
married uh wear a dress which i hated i
hated wearing dresses i would only wear
dresses for the tom jones show because i
thought tom could see me
my grandpa made me wear a dress
and i had to wear my good shoes
and i
brought uh with me uh of the book that
we were reading together at home
my teacher took the book away
because the other children didn't know
how to read yet
so she took the book away and then i got
very upset about that then all the kids
made fun of me because i was wearing
sunday clothes you know i was wearing a
dress and nice shoes
so then i was upset because nobody liked
me and then it really hit the fan when
we went to lunch
because my grandpa always made my lunch
and our favorite lunch with sardine
sandwiches with onions and olive oil
what you can imagine how popular oh yeah
you're already two strikes
holy [ __ ] there's a chapter uh
i wrote in uh i wrote a a kind of a
mash-up memoir cookbook called 50 when i
turned 50.
and i wrote a chapter called
sardine sandwiches make no friends
yeah it was it was so tragic with a
hard-boiled egg an old egg for dessert
uh it's just been ruminating
that's crazy what did do you still enjoy
stuff like that i mean you must still
like that no sardine sandwiches and when
i went home i was crying and hysterical
and i said i was never going back
and that's the first time i remember him
making fun of me oh and just laughing in
my face and the more hysterical i got
the harder he would laugh
and then he went and got a cold cloth
and put it on my head
he took off the fancy shoes
and he made me stretch out and he had me
count my fingers and my toes
and he held my hands up and he said
how many fingers how many digits do you
have
ten
how many toes you have ten
and then he hit my forehead
with the palm of his hand and he said
and what's in there what do you mean
what do you mean what do you have what
do you keep in there
my brain
he said okay so we have 10 fingers we
have 10 toes we have a brain
what are you crying about yeah so you
know how to read and the other children
don't good for you and we can read when
you come home every night wow and oh you
don't want to wear dresses anymore okay
tomorrow you can wear
he would say in english dungarees uh-huh
you know it was italian you used very
everything was very alliterative yes
you can wear your junglers and and
oh they don't like your lunch tomorrow
you can have school lunch whatever
they're eating you can eat we won't we
won't make lunch but you can decide what
you want for lunch wow so really what's
the problem so that's that that's the
way
i i think i don't cry about
uh what an amazing
smart or when i'm not myself
but i cry very easily about everything
else i can try commercials
charming you know we used to tease my
mom who by the way is your biggest fan
wendy
oh
she's going to lose her mind that you
remembered her
she came with you yes oh man
oh she loved it i swear rachel when i
told her i was you were the guest today
it was like
she lit up i mean the pride that she
started beaming so i thank you and um
when she got to be on your show it was
another huge thing for me because i got
to you know make her proud um you are
the high water mark and so uh
i can't thank you enough uh yeah anytime
i also love your show i just love um
what you do on it you're such a relaxed
fun
environment it must be hard to not be
doing it it must be hard to be doing it
in such a different way now
that is a very loaded question yeah
yeah it's not hard the show
this show
um
has been uh just the two of us on this
end just myself and john yeah literally
a year and a day wow um
at the time that we're we're we're
talking about uh yesterday was the one
year
uh watermark of that isn't that crazy
when when we
came here to the adirondacks from new
york city the first thing that happened
um
well we had to just reinvent our lives
the first thing i lost was my privacy
i've always been a person who rolled and
you know this because you've been there
as lucy goosey no blue guards just have
a conversation as as was possible
but
my my space here was where i would write
or paint or read or you know
just relax and just bring people
in my
in in my world
my very close friends sacred and and my
family
so
the idea that
excuse me
the idea that
um
i would now have to open
that part of my life to everyone
was
uh a really big one for me the first
show where i said welcome to our home
i burst into tears i was crying
because it was such a hard line to to
cross i bet and to not be in hair and
makeup nice clothes and vulnerable
whatever
and completely like make it to the world
like all your [ __ ] on your counter
you know even though
it's beautiful i'm looking at it right
now i mean it's just like this isn't my
house oh oh oh okay
okay so then
so then our dog who had cancer she was
15 years old she also had a catastrophic
back injury when she was 13. god that
she was still
battling
um
she was at the end of her life
but because we were in a pandemic
we got to be with her every minute of
the
those last few months at the end of her
vote
so
i had to convert my house into basically
a place to make television so i had to
rebuild the pantry for what we would do
for a tv show versus what i would do in
life
open up the house
and we were taking care of uh
izabu around the clock
so it was a very raw time and then
isabel passed
but she passed in my arms in her own
backyard and john played her banjo all
morning
yeah that was um her favorite instrument
every instrument wow
that's a tough one to play
wow
and she
she had a beautiful
passion
and she would respond to the banjo
rachel she would respond differently
absolutely she would put her head into
the sky oh my god and just rock back and
forth she loved it so much wow she just
loved it
and she passed in my arms and i was
talking to her
when she left
this world and
i thought to myself
how grateful i was
how grateful i was to have a job
how grateful i was to be at home with
her
and how grateful i was to be able to
spend time with her when the world was
dying literally suffering
thousands and thousands of people people
in italy singing into the night out of
pain and sorrow
bodies being stacked in trucks all over
the planet you know
it was just so mind-blowing yeah but i
came to this place of like wow this is
such
this is a really good thing too because
look i got to be with her look i still
have a job look we have so much to be
grateful for and then literally
we went on break from the show
after uh isabeu passed
and then our house burned oh my gosh the
fireplace burped
the fireplace
even though we had the fireplace
cleaned twice a year like you're
supposed to whatever
it it had created
the build-up yeah
from inside the the chimney
spit onto the roof and a guy
on an atv going through the woods
saw our roof on fire and came running
into our backyard screaming
your house is on fire your house is on
fire
and we had just adopted a rescue from
the carolinas bellaboo who's our
our 80 pound very large puppy wow
it was her
first couple of days in our home and
then that whole house burned down it
burned for two days
i watched wow he came across to here
this is the guest house that we only
built two years ago that was only for 15
years holy [ __ ] we built this place for
our friends
and i made it because i drew that house
oh my god and this house was made to be
a tiny one of that it has one great room
in one bedroom that's it this is
literally guest house
it's a mini of my from what i can see
it's still
gorgeous the beams and the very it's
very tall but it's very small oh yeah
it's one homie
and then a little hallway wow and one
bedroom
no bathtubs one one shower like you know
it's a pretty small place i just make it
look big latrine
yes there's still a tree yes there's we
do have running water it's a dumb waiter
situation in a bucket i don't want to
get into it
we came we came across the street i was
in my flip-flops john was in boat shoes
we had nothing but the clothes on her
back holy and our little puppy
and we watched our house burn for two
days it burned for two days i don't
understand how that didn't the fire how
did they not did were they not
attempting to put it out or was just too
out of control
everyone came from uh firefighters and
first responders came from all over but
we live on a mountain we have well water
oh wow it takes a really long time to
get trucks with water that will
be strong enough to put out a fire and
they put out the fire by kind of the
middle of the night but then there was a
pocket
that lit back up the next day
more more people and a couple of trucks
much smaller crew
but a couple of trucks the next day
and then
after the house burned down
you have to have it assessed in the
insurance company right
all the investigators
right
so that goes on
i go back to work four days later and i
teach a 10 000 person class literally 10
000 people from all over the planet for
kids cooking camp wow so i go back to
work immediately
uh as quick as i can but
you know it's how do you do that
emotionally yeah mentally i mean
then when they started
uh
taking away the house
right down to the hole in the ground
every time i do interviews i have to sit
on this side you're staring right at it
i'm staring at the trucks and it went on
for 10
12 days oh boy i watched truck after
truck go by everything i'd put in there
oh
for my 50 years of my life just no
going past the window i had the house
for 15 but of course everything in it
was stuff that was right your whole life
well rachel were you able to get in
there at any point i mean like
you know frantic
right before it got it became
engulfed i ran upstairs to try and take
a few things
my mom's letters all the letters she'd
written me yeah she's very bad macular
degeneration
and she she has trouble writing she
can't see she's blind in the middle
so i wanted to get my mom's letters my
mom's high school ring yeah i wanted to
get our medicines um
just you know literally yeah i would i
would i wouldn't know what to go to
stairs when when we went outside and saw
that the roof was on fire i ran upstairs
to try and get a few things
but i heard
in the wall i heard the fire going oh
and i knew that it was going to come
through that wall because i've had all
these fake fire training drills
i am the first female board member no
longer the only but i was the first
female board member of dennis leary
firefighter foundation
and every year i i suit up and i go
through these drills
where you're put into live fires and
you're with firefighters and they tell
you
everything about what live fire is
so when i heard the fire in the wall
going through the electrical i knew it
was spreading through the roof down all
of the electrical
system
and i knew that the wall in my bedroom
was literally gonna
backdraft and blow up into the room
i turned around immediately and started
running back down the stairs and i was
met face to face with a firefighter in
his full mask the man that had come to
tell us that our house was on fire had
already called them
and john was trying to call them
downstairs
but this this this person
had already told them and he's like you
know get out get out and i'm like i'm
trying to move
yeah
oh yeah they must have been like
frantic they must have been i mean
and then when you see their reaction you
must then think okay this is like but
you already knew you knew that the house
was was going up like i knew it was
going i just wanted to get those few
things you know the letters
my mom's ring all that
but you know it was such a delayed
reaction
my husband didn't cry about it until his
birthday which was about two and a half
weeks later
and he had like a total breakdown
and i it hit me our birthdays are a week
apart we're both in late august and our
house burned on august 9th
it hit me
um uh uh just a little before him
but it was such a delayed reaction
and it really was
waking up in the middle of the night and
realizing i didn't have mama's letters
anymore
and you know she is just such
a resilient lady i was so happy the fire
didn't go down the hill she lives across
the street from me in my in my opinion
and i told mama how upset i was about
the letters
and she really can't see in the middle
so now she started writing me like
literally blind
oh my god so that i can start the
collection
really sweet that's beautiful so
beautiful she's trying so hard it's so
sweet
for valentine's day she's scribbling all
over the card it looks like she had
hieroglyphics very beautiful penmanship
yeah they don't even teach cursive
writing anymore no they don't it's a
lost art
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
hello hello again
[Music]
you sound like you're like me and that
i'm very nostalgic i also have a
terrible memory rachel so i saved those
things from childhood that because
they're they're like uh talisman for my
memory like i i i need them to spark uh
these precious memories that like are so
faint and getting fainter to me so i i i
can't imagine
uh the law that kind of loss and like
you mentioned your grandfather how close
you were and to
lose that were you able to save what
were you able to save anything
you know we really don't know because
when the fire happens
they send in remediators they send in
all the folks and it's their job to
figure that out no it's gonna be like a
surprise box oh that's cool everybody's
doing the best they can
to
fix something or photograph it and make
an image of what was left of it yeah
it's not salvageable in some other way
and people have lost so much more i just
feel silly even no you know whatever's
whatever they they they give us back
great they don't
we'll just make some new memories yeah
yeah but that's that's the other part of
what we've learned out of this year
it became so cathartic to be able to
share with everyone what we went through
and to do our show in a different way we
i you know
i asked my friends in the city our
producers and the folks that uh work in
the control room to help us make a show
out of an iphone and a a computer wow um
you know i said can we focus just more
on we've always done these stories but
can we do like a lot or like every show
can we just focus on real people and how
there's some problems
and you know the whole world is
not only suffering a pandemic
and everything we went through with
the social unrest and
finally people noticing the inequities
um at every level
all of them train wrecking together yeah
and then not having national direction
not having state federal or even local
uh support to get through this
and we just do more and more of people
that are solving that problem instead of
waiting for the
local state or federal government
let's show stories of people that are
pivoting i love that
keeping their businesses alive however
they can and here's how yeah and eating
their neighbors and and and getting kids
still into the process of learning
uh getting people still into reading
books and listening to each other
so we've been doing that's really cool
richard so much of that programming and
it this has been
in many ways the most fruitful year of
our lives and i also wrote a book about
it i wrote a book about the whole
experience and is that out is that
coming out no no it'll come out in the
fall
i delivered it on uh
new year's day okay and my husband
created a new band fastest land animal
by the way next time you have true
barrymore on your show you got to ask
her about when her house bro i don't
know if you know this story i i i i have
talked to her about it yeah i love i i
love drew and she went through the same
thing and she laughed that night
according to her and tom were like able
to i mean they had a moment where
they're watching and burning she said
the same thing it's like what can you do
what are you gonna do yeah it's so bad
yeah yeah i mean the waves of emotion
that we each of us had it was really
about when when we thought of specific
things yes yes yes it wasn't it wasn't
the
the house itself furniture or expensive
stuff it was like the sentimental of
course like john really got freaked out
because he had compiled
his song book for like decades john's a
lawyer by day but he's a musician by
soul and heart and
all he
loves is
so all that stuff was gone it's
everything
so i i like i it took me about 10 years
to compile all my music charts i had
them in like three three three ring
binders
oh you were like a rock
it's incredible and they're they're like
all gone now that's you know like you
just think like it was a huge master
song oh my god arrangements and
everything oh [ __ ] so john do you think
now like does it force you because i've
never had dealt with that kind of loss
does it force you to just be like
well
what are you gonna do i mean like all
that time it's not like it was for
naught it's not like you had you enjoyed
putting all that stuff together but now
does it make you look at things
differently like you're in this house
now this smaller thing does it make you
look at the necessities a little
differently and like what you really
need to be happy
yeah i mean um you just
things kind of hit you randomly like
you'll be like oh i'm gonna
put on this thing or wear this thing or
use this thing and then you're like oh
yeah that's gone so it's a little uh
it's kind of like someone pulled
the tablecloth out from under you yeah
but um i mean the most important thing
is no one
died
yeah yeah i i think no one we got to the
point where we were just like oh well so
what we're alive
we can laugh
yeah most of the stuff you can you can
replace obviously her mom's letters are
irreplaceable well she's trying to
replace them
no but i think that you pivoted
by making the new band right
when you know
you found an outlet yeah
you know i wrote a book you wrote an
album like you did yeah you you worked
through it and i i think in your head by
creating something new for yourself and
did you john did you record that uh in
the house in the did you were you about
yeah we did it um remotely i have a
little recording studio up here
and everyone else in the band has their
own little studios they're all all over
the country that's so cool um so we were
able to through a combination of zoom
and uh a music program called audio
movers okay you were able to
uh rehearse and record remotely
and uh it was actually kind of easy it's
actually easier than going to a studio
and doing it live because
normally you know you go to a studio the
drummer's going to be sitting there
eq'ing his kick drum you know with the
producer for
the engineer for like eight hours uh-huh
just really indulging sitting there
playing video games sitting on the couch
in the lounge so this way we could uh
all be at home is that get down to
business
yeah let's do this
and then we take a day or two off while
whoever was doing their part would work
on their part and come back we listen to
it and be like cool let's do this next
part that's so cool john was john was
very very lucky well we both are because
we both care so much about all the
instruments
a a entirely separate building from our
home was the garage
and above the garage was the studio
and i drew the house and i said can we
make like a little covered walkway
so we had this connector between the
house and the garage this long hallway
it burned all the way through to the
door
all the way up to the door
and it stopped
and when they didn't burn the studio
managed to survive so john when that's
happening obviously you must be watching
it you must be like uh [ __ ] like we were
watching yeah night long
you know like i i didn't grab a lot of
stuff because i'm like whatever we'll
have a little bit of a fire damage and
we'll go up and get our stuff you know
tomorrow but then like it kept going and
going from like eight o'clock at night
to like one o'clock in the morning we're
watching as this fire is engulfing our
house are you like
are you running around thinking like oh
i i'm just imagining
you get trying to get buckets of water
or trying to do practical things but
and we had a little puppy a tiny rescue
puppy that had already been in a kill
shelter
foster homes
a little tiny puppy that had been in you
know yeah horrible circumstances already
uh you know
that poor puppy's like that puppy really
no one would let you back in there i i
also can't help but think maybe you
shouldn't wear flip-flops anymore you
just told two
horrible stories that both involve
flip-flops
i've been i'm pretty solid um
okay
how about crocs
are you a fan of crocs um
i look like i was gonna go dine at
margaritaville
shorts and like dark shoes yeah my
brother and i we call those that look um
we call those people ready-faced
pleasure hounds so we just got back from
naples you know them you know the type
they love jimmy buffett they're and
they're a little ready from the sun
maybe a little alcohol too much alcohol
and they're pleasure hounds they just
like soak it in um
i i that's who i am all summer by the
way uh well that's so i also love that
you adopted another dog you you um you
had a brief morning period but uh you
have an incredible organization
immediately yeah immediately there's no
uh my first girl was boo
and i found her in um
the penny saver
it was an open letter in the penny saver
oh wow
the local like buy motorcycles or old
tvs
and uh someone thought boo is junk
yeah sad
was my first dog
um and the letter was a woman who was
pregnant and she was worried that the
dog would be too rambunctious oh yeah
and she she wasn't planning on having
another baby and she had a a small pit
bull and she was worried because pit
bulls always get put down if they go to
a shelter so she wrote this open letter
and i drove out in my truck and i
brought boo home with me that night and
john met boo towards the end of her life
like two years
then we got isabu together my favorite
name is isabella
and i don't have human kids we didn't
get married until i was 37 he was 38 and
i started a television show a magazine
a brand and we adopted isabel all in one
year so isn't it
and
uh
so isabel became like the center of our
world and i i i changed it to
isabu instead of isabella so i could
always remember boo yeah and when we
lost isabu she's buried in our orchard
there where she loved to play
apple balls she would catch apples and
just crunch on them right away
yeah she crunch on did she delicate with
them would she try to treat him like a
ball oh no she would have a monster
pit ball right
she's like a she's like a big red-nosed
pimple oh wow like a crocodile yeah and
a tongue like gene simmons yes
she she would slobber all over it and
spit it out and then pop up again and
wait for her next pop-up of apple ball
oh cute a couple apple trees so she's in
the apple orchard
and the second um she passed john and i
said we have to talk to our friends
we we created our our brand to support
uh paying it forward in life first
first human beings with our yamaha
initiative for kids and then
our we created our animal food to
support um non-kill shelters and rescue
animals that are in kill shelters that's
amazing it's and it's to date uh you
can't say this because it'd be bragging
but i can it's amazing you've raised
over 65 million dollars to help animals
in need and um
yeah more than 70 just oh really
yeah
65 70 something like that let's say 70.
the animal food
human stuff we
all the pots and pans and stuff it's
less but we've been doing that for
longer it's just that people buy more
dog food than they do
right right well my mother's so our
human initiative hasn't quite taken off
well the yama organization i should say
it's also just during kovid uh they
you've raised over four million dollars
for coveted relief um so you're helping
yeah the animals and the humans uh yamo
organized so how can people donate or
it's just about buying those products no
no no it's just anything you you
i i didn't want to do that because um we
did one event and the cost of the event
took away so much of that yeah
stupid just buy something so we just we
just made well no and pots and pans yes
well
our brand supports yummo that's the
human initiation okay and nutrition
that money
is is for the animal rescue okay now
we put it under one big blanket the four
million we gave away was just this one
year for specifically coveted relief
that
that was targeted for
just literally targeted only for covert
relief but
all that uh
constantly yeah and everything that we
sell
a pan a kitchen cloth whatever
it goes to fund
uh
improving public school food
scholarships for public school kids who
want to go into anything that's
even remotely food or nutrition related
um and to feed the hungry as long as we
don't have them uh and and unfortunately
over the last five years it's become an
enormous relief effort
our largest partner now is probably jose
andrus and and worldwide world central
kitchen oh they're great because
because we've had to do so much just
relief of natural disaster to give
people literally water and food right
god um
what was originally designed to be all
about nutrition and improving school
food yeah
has now become um largely in the last
several years
emergency funds um
and water literally i do stuff with no
kid hungry and i remember a couple years
it was only a couple years ago when when
they would say it was one in six kids
were food insecure which is a horrible
it's a horrible number but this year i i
think it's climbed to one in four and
it's closer to one and four in our
industry it absolutely has and they are
they are partners of ours for many many
many years well
um as well they're they're wonderful
wonderful people
thank you i mean thanks for it's
incredible what you're doing i you
mentioned um
cafeteria school food uh what what would
you say is the number one issue in terms
of what what is it something that like a
kind of easy way to just address um
making school food a lot more nutritious
and and um palatable
ask ask your school in your community
what you can do you know they will take
a garden
they will take a window box they will
take you giving your time to teach uh
latchkey kids how to make nutritious
food after school they will take your
advice they will listen to you if you
say i'm not happy with what you're
feeding my dad
i think that under this administration
and i know secretary vilsack a long time
uh i'm glad he's back and i think that a
lot of the changes that were made in the
obama administration years
will be brought back
those standards will be um reintroduced
to our schools we had come a long way we
had gotten some increases um in in
ten cents a kid but it adds up
uh uh
per day is is where we kind of got to
there
but i think that a lot of that's gonna
come back now i think we're in a really
good time uh joel berg feels uh our our
friend and a
huge advocate for school nutrition
you know the thing is people say to me
all the time and i find it really
insulting actually but people say to me
all the time why do you care about
school food you don't have kids i was
going to say that i was going to say
that i'm like well uh
i'm kidding i'm kidding i'm an american
yeah of course
yeah you have a big hairy kid
there yes john
[Applause]
i'm sorry i didn't ask about it you know
i had i
i ate some cheese i feel better okay
well
all need to care about it of course
because
i you know i mean it pays so many things
and we all fight about health care costs
well you want to know how to lower them
right why don't you treat your kids a
little better start early and
holistically give them a good education
improve our infrastructure in our
schools and we'd all be much happier as
a country another another shout out to
wendy i was so lucky to have a mother
who prepared in fact i have such guilt
sometimes rachel about i think back to
some of those lunches she prepared like
really painstaking like healthy
delicious little meals she'd write notes
with her little like curly hair i love
you you know and i would sometimes trade
these things that took her a while to
make and there was love in them i would
trade them for like twinkies and ho hos
and crap you know because that's the
stuff i wanted because it was like
forbidden fruit
um
you know my mom was the same i mean not
only did i start with starting
sandwiches but the only cookie my mom
ever bought was like a stelladoro
breakfast treat
oh right so it was your was your grandpa
who taught you how to make that stuff
and john do you ever i'm curious if you
ever do any of the cooking at home what
what that uh is like um i i definitely
make all the drinks oh yeah you're an
excellent cook when i first met josh
he told me what he made for dinner the
night before and i was gonna set him up
with a male friend of mine because he
said he wasn't a chef and i just assumed
he was a very handsome gay man
i later that night i proved to her oh
you did not okay
okay i'm curious what do you remember
what he said he made that it made you
assume absolutely tell him what you read
i made uh tilapia
with um
uh tomatillos oh and i made a mock shoe
spilling out of an avocado
wow i don't know tell me you wouldn't
assume well at the time maybe but i've
i'm now looking at him again not to
generalize because many gay men are
hairy and have this luke um but uh yeah
i'm a bear you're a bear yeah you're an
otter let's say it's gonna be more of an
otter you're not i don't think you're
big enough to be a bear yeah yeah
probably not big enough to be i don't
want to offend the bear community he's
not one of us
um what did you make last justin well
that's a good question i'll be cooking a
lot of um these i shouldn't say this
it's a rival chef but jamie oliver has a
five ingredient cookbook do you know
this yeah um so i've been really into
that uh hannah mckinnon is somebody
really like um your stuff i like i love
burgers so i want to ask you all about
burgers i know that's your specialty um
but i cooked a uh a lamb
a stir-fry cauliflower mints thing yeah
this book has been really invaluable at
tilapia i'm curious about because i just
heard that it is
a no-no you can't they feed them it's
what they feed them is disgusting
they well st john's fish was
a very cheap fish that's why people use
so much tilapia um why
uh a young man uh with well this is back
in like two thousand apartments right i
wouldn't have known he'd be making
tilapia as opposed to sustainable black
cod we didn't know these things it was
poor and this was a really we didn't
have whole foods in the neighborhood
right right that's right i you know i
went to like the you know the bodega and
picked up whatever was sitting in the
freezer no i'm not judging 2 000 john
i'm asking
21 2000 john's a whole different oh
forget i don't want to get into 2000
2000 john if we get into it we'll
probably get canceled and we can't we
don't want that um yeah we'll never see
or hear from you again
yeah no but 2021 john are you guys you
strike me as people who are very
conscientious about
sure i buy my seafood from a place
called lobster place in chelsea market
shout out
they sell only sustainable seafood i
also like fulton fish they ship as well
for sure
war shores great too
there's a lot of people that are
terrific purveyors that have great fair
prices and they make the promise that
they chef's garden i've heard chef's
garden yes
um they have kept us literally alive and
our show looking beautiful
or the the entire year
um we have a beautiful gardens but
unfortunately when the house burned we
lost all of our
uh way to irrigate oh right and died too
do you know what a drag that is man your
house burns down and you watch your
garden die oh and there was this summer
it was probably the peak of the it was
summer yeah
it was going into harvesting everything
there's no way human beings could water
a you know a giant garden like that oh
i'm so irrigation oh rachel just lost
every ability to pump water yeah i'm so
into gardening i have a little garden
but i love it so much i got so into that
too this summer that um that of all the
things you've said and
uh of course the the letters and stuff
would kill me but like that would re
that would have torn me up to lose after
you know you're cultivating this thing
for months and like oh [ __ ] oh years
years yeah we would burn and turn the
soil oh man
john buys all the seed from italy uh
it's every year from my dog to me on
mother's day i get the seed because we
can't plant here why italy
well because we're both italian and uh
italians make good produce babe oh okay
okay italian tomato
[Music]
hello hello again
we'll meet again
[Music]
what is your go-to burger rachel if you
were having company over uh you got the
grill going um what would you cook for
like let's say i was coming over let's
say we were close enough that let's say
you actually invite me over
well i would invite
wendy's there she's losing her mind you
know you know what a geek i am for you
come on yeah i think that the the burger
that john likes the most is my big smack
which is my version of a big mac but he
actually prefers it made from impossible
now
and we again we're not vegetarian it's
good but we love impossible so much yeah
the texture of it and i actually made
the big smack which is my uh russian
thousand island dressing
which is uh sour cream worcestershire
hot sauce salt pepper grated garlic
such delicious dressing it's all about
the dressing and then the finely chopped
uh
uh
super crispy iceberg lettuce all over oh
yeah onions and then and the pickles and
i
every bite has to be the same so i hand
slice the pickles and make the pickles
everywhere whatever
but
i think that that's the most popular
because it's the one that's probably
most familiar to people because it
almost mirrors like a big mac
i think my dressing is better yeah i'm
sure i put the impossible next to
ground beef and i can't remember if i
got it at dixon or pat lafreda but it
was like the best ground you know 80 20
wow no [ __ ] and john chose i did a blind
tasting the impossible next to the beef
and i picked the impossible as the beef
burger no kidding
oh this is great to know you know i just
talked to jane not to brag but jane
goodall was just on the show a couple
days ago um dr jane and uh she
that's the biggest thing i said what can
we do you know because she's really uh
going out of her way to try to to try to
change the world and she said
she said that is the biggest thing that
people can do is if you can't cut out
meat completely eat less meat so i've
been trying to eat less that's what we
do too yeah we are trying to make it
much less and we have so many friends
that are pescetarians or vegetarians
the only way we've been able to
socialize at all in over a year
is to do cook-alongs so we cook in
everyone's discipline
so
and i try and teach in every discipline
you know and i i try and show on
literally on the television show we made
tuscan meat sauce the other day with
impossible we made peachy you know which
big fat spaghetti and a meat sauce that
was
no meat we
try and show as much uh pescatarian and
vegetarian and it can and vegan as as we
can
um without making people feel alienated
yeah or forcing an agenda or like you
know being going about it and i try and
teach you balance you know here
my own mom became a vegetarian in 83.
really
it lasted until the pandemic now she's a
flexitarian that's still pretty good
this just a long time
83 to so so during she she went about
three years only vegetable and then the
pandemic came and she
it's straight give me some salami and
steaks yes
that's what broken i just wanted a
little bit can i just have a bite of
meat well uh rachel what is the thing
what would you say is the thing because
i know my thing if that would prevent me
from going full vegan the thing or the
thing that would be the hardest to give
up uh i because my vegan
very easily very easily but what's the
meat thing it wouldn't break my heart a
bit really i would never be a vegan
because i have to have cheese i
i have to have
actual sheep smell yeah
cow's milk i see what you've been
through in the name of cheese you you've
you've proven your love your loyalty to
cheese but so so that would be the thing
for vegan what about what meat would you
miss the most would it be burgers
um
well now that i have impossible i don't
think i don't miss burgers oh that's a
great endorsement
no seriously i i have nothing to do with
the company whatsoever not yet i love it
not yet right yeah um
i
i could easily live on just seafood i
don't know that there's meat i would
miss i know what john will say what what
is the meat you would miss what is the
category of meat you would miss the
moist chocolate uh pork yeah
john's middle name is
salumi
oh that's better than pork i love salami
i love bacon
pork chops i love just every year it
could be john
kusamano
i would give him a bouquet
of 12 different
salamis from all over the world
that he could carry around but i hear
impossible's working on uh i'm working
on salamis oh really
we don't have room in the fridge anymore
because we live in such a much smaller
place so this year i made roses out of
uh sliced uh sharp cream
i made roses out of prosciutto and stuff
and i decorated the plate like it was a
dozen that's that's very romantic and
kind of disgusting
but there's nothing like being in
tuscany and having like a place a plate
of thinly sliced like salamis and a
glass of
rosso to matuchino i mean that's just
you know it's funny when you talk about
salami my first thought this is
disgusting but um i just think about i
just think about burps it makes me think
about burps salami burps there's nothing
is there anything worse salami burp well
a hot dog burps pretty bad that's pretty
i guess
burps anything to do with like
hard-boiled eggs yes that's true no
bueno on either end yeah you get the
whole sulfur yeah
that smells like sulfur yeah maybe
sardine onion burp can't be good yeah
i'm picturing your classmates um yeah so
my classmates when i was in kindergarten
at mashpee central school yeah did you
ever did you end up winning them over
did you and how did you like what was
your um what was your group like what
was your social life like the gas the
gas crisis came and then another gas
crisis came and my family closed their
restaurants and we moved so i didn't
have to worry about it oh because they
were in the they were in the adirondacks
right we were no we were in cape cod
when i was little
and we moved to the adirondacks where
i've been since uh the second half of
first grade wow because the gas crisis
we really had two gas crises back to
back
and that is how my family's restaurants
went out of business my mom had to go to
work
she ran restaurants for another man for
50 years wow and she got her job with
him when we left cape cod we moved to
the adirondacks when i was in
the second half of first grade that oh
when i was at nashville when i came home
crying and grandpa was consoling me that
was literally when i was in kindergarten
oh wow and we lived in a yankee barn
in um it's a new seabury and i went to
mashpee and this is why she
unfortunately for me is a red sox fan oh
yeah
you know it's like uh romeo juliet the
yeah the capulets in the montague
[Music]
bracelets and the romulus yeah
oh how great or do you guys go to the
games do you ever go to yankee state not
fenway
all the time i mean of course houston of
course well we used to we are hoping to
once again i know i can't wait i can't
wait uh so it's gonna be so great yeah i
i seriously i can't wait not only do i
go to the games but when we go to yankee
stadium
they don't have
um relish i can't find relish you bring
your own i bring balance oh really
onions
and they don't let you bring in bags
like you have to wear uh bring a fanny
pack or something oh yeah and i go
packing chopped onions
yeah now you just have more confidence i
have to hide i have to hide all these
onions in my butt because they don't lay
in which can't help the smell yeah which
does
if they're fermenting condiment
they're fermented
anal onions
now speaking of fermented anal onions
it's kimchi it's kimchi yeah they're a
lot of probiotics in those butt onions
um you know city city field actually is
really good food now they um i think i
think they even have shake shack
upgraded
everything well they they have shape
check there they have shake shack and
not to sell you on the mets um because i
know your yankees fan but um this is so
fun but i just have a quick little
lightning round uh speed round question
okay well i suck at this makes fun of me
all the time
well and rachel it's sort of a sucky
lightning round because some of these
questions require a little bit more
thought so
it's also my fault and i suck at asking
them what is your most commonly used
emoji it's that thank you um you know
kind of non-mistake kind of thing and uh
in the sunglasses like cool yep yep yep
basically oh and thank you this so you
do the hands together as uh oh thank you
i've been doing a lot of that thank you
yes well there's been a lot of gratitude
can you imagine having to ask uh dr jane
goodall that question i did
i had to what did she say oh it was she
was sweet and lovely about it oh i don't
no emojis no i it was
she didn't shame me she didn't shame me
she could have um i felt shame though uh
if you could be a professional athlete
what sport would you play baseball for
sure baseball uh a particular position
well i did throw from the mound right
over the plate to veritech um it wasn't
a heater but it didn't touch the ground
but it wasn't a fouchy who did it yeah
take that back to fouchy
the only thing i can uh make fun of that
impressive person for uh by the way i
wouldn't reach the mound either that's
um
because i imagine the pressure must be
enormous it was incredible and there was
a fire in the hotel that we were staying
at the night before and we literally had
to stand in the street for hours i
barely flashed
and i had practiced
for yeah
like months i went to gainers barn
in clifton park new york and i practiced
for months so that i would be able to
throw from the mound and it'd be
straight i took it so seriously i did
not want to whist out yeah and when i
went out there
james taylor was there he was singing
the national anthem like i was trying oh
my god very tech very tech is down there
with his glove and i'm like
i thought i was going to pass it ah it
was literally hyperventilating and man
it was good for you
on the money that is awesome the plate
toyota moment
did you over celebrate did you do you
look back at it like oh i really i i
geeked out
oh dude yeah absolutely freaking i would
yeah it's like say winning the world
series
we got to go inside the green monster
that's awesome
with the owners well that sounds awesome
for john
we drank premium liquor had nice food
that's great god you guys are fun um if
uh if you could have one snack food for
the rest of your life john i'm curious
about your answer too what would uh what
would your go-to snack food consider a
snack food man
that's true well like let's say you're
on the couch like a packaged product
you're a little stoned you're sure
um from canada
dill pickle
corny lays canadian please wow okay the
little tiny ones
from canada okay wow delicious friends
in canada canada send them to us and
they send john ketchup pringles oh no
kidding they're very good i mean my
snack go-to snack is salami yes
it always comes back to the salad yes
you look like you you might enjoy a
salami i mean that as a compliment
why did i mean that um so you could just
eat salami like you're just watching the
game and just oh absolutely in fact i
did about three seconds before i joined
rachel here oh really oh i can always
hear him in the pantry i hear the
drawer open like i just opened the paper
thing wow and she's not recoiling
if anything she you guys seem very close
physically she doesn't seem to be
recoiling um
what what is your um what is your
favorite movie sequel of all time
godfather too oh yeah yeah first right
is that a dumb question two i consider
like one one one film my favorite
screenplay of all time not that you
asked is network by patty chaiowski oh
my favorite a cinematic uh that you know
cinematically my my favorite film was
once for arabia but my favorite film was
godfather one and two so we would have
to be godfather too
who directed network was that cindy
lamet was uh it was okay wow you know i
don't think i've ever seen it i'm
embarrassed
before you come on my show you must
watch network okay you hear me all right
it's your assignment i it's a good
assignment because i i want to watch it
and i it's one of those movies where
it's been out so long and like i kind of
need it to be brilliant it's brilliant i
bet i bet um i've also never seen um
i don't even want to tell you uh
pretty woman i've never seen the
entirety of pretty woman oh yeah no
that's okay that's less of a loss okay
all right all right um what is your goat
you guys must both love you strike me as
karaoke people
what would be your go-to karaoke songs
we sing a lot of songs together when
we're in italy we uh john always plays
with the super group so there's a couple
that i sing with them
um you don't have a karaoke song
back i haven't done karaoke in a long
time back when i did karaoke my like
show-off song was uh youtube pride in
the name of love oh wow john has an
arrangement
zeppelin wow acquire angels oh my god
incredible sings the hell out of the
beatles too like you wow there's so many
songs that john does covers of with his
band for fun oh cool well i i actually
prefer his brother oh wow he's amazing
that's high praise what's the one we
just did um together honey
right back where you started from oh
right back where we started from oh my
god so that's my car okay
i i did quite a good job there okay okay
it was on our show we i did it with his
band oh cool because
i got a feeling by uh
yes
i got a feeling by the beatles
crushes that crushes it i love that so i
was going to ask you one of the
questions is beatles are the rolling
stones if you have a favorite
well beetles without beetles they'd be
nothing else
i love i you know and i hate that his
band does that all the time like
rankings who's better
don't rank it i know the sponsors are
great the stones are amazing right
without the beetles of course like where
are you
and if you go to a bar and you want to
put on a couple i haven't heard the
beatles in a while you know i i it's
been a while i'm going to put on like a
couple beatles songs what are the
go-to's i'm putting on revolution uh
nine
clear around the bar
number nine nightmare sounds yes those
dissonant weird empty out the bar
because then there's more booze for me
this might be
awkward to answer around one another but
who was your i don't think so you guys
seem comfortable with it who was your
very first celebrity crush
oh i know yours oh
tom jones for sure i would put on a
dress when i was a little girl only
because i thought tom could see me and
the first time he came on my show
he came over for dinner that night and i
made him rabbit catchy toy by the way
and
because rabbit's his favorite dish and
when he came on the show i couldn't even
look at him
and i was sweating so hard the picture
of me like
hugging him like this all you can see is
like i'm pitted out that's from my boobs
to my waist it's so gross that'd be a
great name for your memoir freaking like
panic sweat everywhere oh it's you so
you like regressed it that isn't that
funny rachel i've had that experience
with meeting people that i as a kid like
really like was had crushed on and i you
kind of regressed back to um
that child like
yeah
that's so funny
it was so creepy and when i was a little
girl i was so obsessed with tom so i
would put my dress on and i would stand
in front of the television and i try and
mimic every word and i try and sing
along but i didn't know what he was
saying and my grandfather would turn his
chair around i called it the blueberry
chair it had blue roses on it but they
look like blueberries to me he'd turn
his chair around and he would watch me
instead of the tv i would i get it i was
so hilarious i get it i would too yeah i
wouldn't watch what tom jones i'd rather
watch my sweet granddaughter do like a
funny enactment
my first song that i learned all the
words to is delilah which is a very
violent and misogynistic
it's about a man who stabs a woman and
it's all her fault because that [ __ ]
was cheating
so i would go around singing delilah as
like a four-year-old
oh my god it's hilarious it's like [ __ ]
better have my money
what's your favorite fruit oh wow that's
so tough pomegranate icing oh yeah
pomegranate i love pomegranate and very
good for you
i love to cook with it i love it it's
salads and cocktails i love it i just
learned that technique where you cut it
and you you hit it with a spoon
oh that's what you do or or in water
yes you peel it under water and the
thing it's great
um i love pomegranate yeah i love
pomegranate yeah almost done who would
you want to play you and john who do you
think should play rachel don't say
somehow in the biopic and her biopic
yeah
who wants to watch my life i'm a
waitress and a cook look uh fair foster
majors of course uh-huh
but she's not the person in your mind
still um
yeah i don't know if they could say you
uh bob schneider looks like your older
brother
he could play you but he's about a foot
and a half taller okay
and i i don't think bob acts i think
he's pretty much just a musician artist
and sculptor but but there's often
crossover um
who uh while you think about that do you
guys have a favorite uh muppet character
when i was a kid i loved the muppets
growing up oh god i love the muppets so
much i love that the old man in the
balcony oh stanley and waldorf but i
loved beaker and i love you to chef yeah
of course chef and i love beaker and i
love the um the two little muppets with
the telephone too that were on actually
the
the weekend yes
yes
yes
you know i love animals i do too you
love kermit too i mean who doesn't love
christmas of course it's hard enough and
i i i made a green bean casserole with
kermit when the muppet movie came out
yeah it's cool
and cookie monster's business
i love cookies yes let's test mystery
that's but still a muppet i would say
anybody who was at the wedding
in the world yeah got the goop in the
eyes i used to have you here
in his in his chicken oh yeah that's
right the flying and who's that guy who
had the flying sardines you were talking
about sardines
remember that guy
and museum
um oh i love him um you know it's funny
you were talking about the swedish chef
of course you like the swedish chef but
i used to i loved
it
but i loved his hands and somebody on
the show
pointed that out that it freaked them
out
well he had human hands yeah yeah
because it would creep you out because
it had people hands yes and apparently
in some of the earlier swedish chef
stuff um they were actual hands they it
wasn't like the puppeteer put them into
muppet felt gloves right right and so he
said that was
people here
yeah um okay you guys i i know the
answer this seinfeld are
oh seinfeld yes okay and i don't know
this but i'm curious ketchup or mustard
i guess relish i love every content
except mayonnaise i don't mind now if i
make it myself you like mustard more but
i love all condiments i i am an equal
opportunity condiment okay muster um and
i.e salsa or salsa
uh i think we would just like to say
salsa
uh
people just like to say it um you guys
are the best i am out of time but i
could do this for hours i i can't wait
to hang out with you guys we had so much
fun thank you so much for having us
thanks guys i will see you very soon
oh likewise
thank you for my mother's pride
give wendy my love
god thank you thanks guys see you soon
so that happened
is that too thick my accent because hers
is very it's thicker than i remember no
it's not that but like my ma'am that
sounds um it's two-way chicago
to wisconsin but hers there's a parallel
between upstate new york i thought she
was from rochester when she was talking
she has a
upstate new york that vibe that's where
our family's from
yeah so you you picked up but it is
close enough so that it's probably the
same similar no not really it's a hybrid
so she i guess she's from
born in cape cod that area um eastern
massachusetts then moved to
uh
like westchester area right oh no i
thought upstate new york that's where
but that's not that far upstate oh yeah
no it's like a couple hours it's not
it's not like six hours up like it's
pretty far adirondacks is north of the
catskills so it's at least two hours
three i thought she was we should know
this i thought she was
i thought she spent her formative years
in west westchester area oh
why did i why do i not know that poconos
i thought the poconos oh god but poconos
is not westchester yeah isn't it oh [ __ ]
anyway
she i'm pretty sure with her act well
then how do you explain ma'am when she
says like that's an act that's an
upstate new york it is and she reminds
me about me a lot of um our cousin
carolyn yeah she sure does
that will be interesting to six people
maybe
um okay yeah she was uh she's very
you know
she's a great talker
yes she is and which sometimes can be
a little tough to navigate because i
don't it's it's hard to she said so many
things i wanted to comment on are kind
of like you know well she made your job
a lot easier she sure did you didn't
have to pivot anywhere you didn't have
to no i just went along for the ride
exactly yeah i i like which was nice
i clung on to her into her uh coattails
she talked so much it's like she didn't
take a breath the first 10 minutes well
got a lot to say yes well she had a lot
she's an amazing talker yes yes and i
she's had a show i mean she's been
talking for
professionally for 20 years it makes
sense she has her own show yeah of
course it does she's used to talking
yeah and she um also like she's been
with her husband in this space she
talked about for you know
a year and so it all that also felt like
it made sense like if if i just heard
about this interview like wait what do
you mean the husband joined uh but it
happened so organically seems like a
nice guy yeah super nice and um i
actually really enjoy talking to i like
seeing the both of them interact you can
tell a lot about
somebody like rachel uh by just how she
interacts with somebody that close to
her and that was nice ping pong yes yes
they had a very easy
flow with one another
huh
uh when she was describing her injuries
uh i almost had to turn it off in the
beginning and it was you didn't turn it
off you stopped it i almost had to turn
it off for good i thought oh yeah you
did you said i had to ask you how much
longer this conversation was going to
continue because because that would last
another 30 seconds i didn't think i
could do it yeah yeah because you get
sweet you i mean i was getting that way
when i heard
no i don't have erotic goosebumps thanks
for pointing that out
uh when she was talking about her
uh ripping off her the fingers coming
off is really gross
but for me the finger nails coming off
yes yes yes that gets me
i don't know if you've been like cuts to
my core
my stomach i don't know if you've ever
done like a deep dive like i've gone
down like a wikipedia hole about um some
of the martyrs like some of the no and i
and i won't i know well well some of the
north american ones you know when they
were captured by i don't i don't want to
talk about it okay i want to talk about
that yeah yeah because yeah nail issues
finger anti-male issues
that's my kryptonite it's i mean i have
a lot of kryptonite
you're cats
yeah it's so arrogant for someone who is
not even close to being superman saying
like this is my kryptonite like there's
one thing also that like without this
others
yeah yes if it weren't for this like
squeamishness about nails coming off i'd
be able to save the world
my kryptonite people use that a lot i
never realized how arrogant that it is i
haven't either you don't both have to
realize
or achilles heal that's an arrogant
thing to be like my achilles heel
otherwise i'm like achilles like the one
part about me that like is vulnerable is
my vow
who does that remind you of go hannah
brown yeah um
bachelor nationals might be reminded of
her too that's of course yeah uh yeah
achilles heel yeah but that's from a
very specific thing i know that that
comes from a specific thing whereas he
was struck on the but
uh kryptonite in superman he's a
fictional character right that's true uh
do you think she actually remembered
mom's name
i wondered that or do you think she did
a little quick google search before the
interview being the professional that
she is either way it's cool yes she took
the time to do that if she remembered it
amazing memory i wouldn't be at all
insulted i don't think our mother she's
listening by the way so we can just talk
to her directly and she's definitely
listening i don't think mom i don't
think you should be insulted if she
didn't remember your name not because
you didn't make an impression but
because she must she meets so many
people how the [ __ ] can i remember that
well
uh i'm surprised you remember bro
here's the argument mom is both very
memorable
as a person i think and she has a pretty
unique name
wendy is a pretty memorable name it is
even though i know i know when he
started as peter pan yeah yeah i didn't
realize that i always thought wendy had
there been wendy's for generations but
then you think about like i'm trying to
imagine like a medieval wendy it just
doesn't go it just doesn't fit i wonder
if he thought of the name
jamberry thought of the name
because it sounded like windy and there
was something
ethereal and uh fluid about that
character
how do you think he settled on wendy for
that character by the way great pull the
jam barry to say so casually yeah it
would have taken me a second i don't
know that's a good question or did it
come from gwendolyn
oh i always thought it came from
gwendolyn you might be right gwen i used
to love that name gwen why gwen stacy
that's uh from spiderman okay uh but
when that's a good question we should we
should have jamberry on too soon
what was jan barry's deal was he like a
pervert
no
isn't there something about like or am i
thinking of peter pan complex
like people with
was he i wonder if anyone said that
sentence today
in this country
what's the deal with jamberry what's it
pervert
in this country by the way you just
turned off a lot of berryheads listening
oh barry berryman and berry women
um who said that recently they were like
i don't i don't like fruit oh sal
i like berries though berries berries i
love salsa
um i agree with her husband
about pork about john porcus about pork
being the best
meat it is a grocery pork pork
but you know all the think about this
all the meats are gross yeah salami beef
yes
beef is gross word too you're right
chicken's not a bad word chicken
i said it grossly but um pork's the best
though if i had to eliminate or i'd
rather if i had to save one meat
i would definitely save pork over beef
and chicken
yeah yeah
you're a porker from way back an old
porker you know i
but good news about the impossible
burgers great news yeah i was going to
say like this is stuff that i keep
thinking what jane goodall said and how
important that is to not eat i aspire to
eating less meat how important that is
stupid um yeah i know and now i i in
fact pork is is an ingredient one of the
things i think the thing that would be
hardest will be
the hardest for me to give up which is
soup dumplings mm-hmm
xiao long bao shell set up wrong i was
so confident about it uh and shout out
to
excellent dumpling house in new york if
you are looking for really delicious
dumplings they have all different types
vegetarian too it's a great place great
place but i think the technology behind
impossible burgers is getting better and
better and i bet in a few years or
hopefully sooner
they're going to master how to replicate
bacon and oh for sure like other pork
related foods in such a wonderful way
who's saying that somebody with real
authority somebody who like an expert
was saying that that will happen for
sure
i forget who but it's somebody like not
us who has authority was saying it so
i'm i look forward to that
that's good that could save the world it
could that the company innovation the
companies designing these foods are
going to be
the heroes for sure i mean if our
civilization is supposed to shiro's yes
it's yes i don't mean to laugh but
shiro's is is that
you can that's no longer that's not a
thing that you can't say heroes right i
think you can say heroes because you can
also say shiro's yeah i can't but not
but like heroes he is not implied that's
not a part of hero i mean i know the
letters are but hiro doesn't imply
masculinity no no i know okay but shiro
has become a popular word to say it has
i see that a lot on social media you do
yeah quite a bit yeah all right well
okay was that your stomach yeah are you
hungry for impossible bacon that i hate
to say this but that wasn't a hungry
noise okay say no more okay
well also you may speaking of food you
made a delicious pasta last night that i
think rachel ray would have been proud
of from the jamie oliver cookbook yes i
wonder how she felt about me mentioning
that my friend liz turned me on to oh
great book it is a great book and she i
i really like jamie all right not to
talk about him on
rachel's episode too late i did i know
how would you feel though i mean i i i
don't think i would be bothered if like
on this someone on this podcast was like
you know what probably in fact this
happened before they're like i really
like this podcast i wouldn't be like
insulted by that or
yeah it would be weird if they only
wanted to talk about jake gyllenhaal the
whole time
that's true that's true oh i think it'd
be kind of funny too yeah that that's
true yeah
um she really shamed you for not seeing
network oh my god i've never seen
network either i've always wanted to i
should i know i should it's supposed to
be amazing but she really let you have
it uh wait let me do an impression of
her and you tell me that you haven't
seen network
um i've actually never seen network what
i know oh my god i can't do it i can't
do it justice it's hard to commit to she
has so much energy that there were times
where she was like i noticed when i
re-listened to it where she was like
like catching her breath she was like
doing this
really interesting monologues and like
stuff that but there's so much
information he does have a lot of energy
i wonder how much of that is due to
her clean good diet oh yeah maybe i bet
people with that level of energy have to
eat really good food don't you think
well it's like maggie q matt i've been
doing this not enough show friend of the
show friend of ours um activate you this
uh probiotic mixture that her commercial
was so i saw her commercial was so
compelling she's been telling me to get
it for years but um
because she knows about your issues yeah
you know i get a little bloody and i can
have some gas and who can't i'm not
ashamed i'm a little ashamed of it but
um yeah and by the way it's been helping
a lot uh but um mazel tov yeah but i
also feel like i have there's this thing
called vito mito vitality and it's like
a mitochon thing for your mitochondria
and your cells and uh i don't know what
else is in it but um it's been given
i've felt a lot more have i see more i
don't know what else is in it but i take
it but i trust maggie q
yeah uh have i seen more energetic um
yeah maybe i think i have maybe i mean
now you seem energetic well yeah i'm
sure subconsciously i'm like oh yeah
i've also had four cups
let's read a letter okay okay
behind you okay
that's true i haven't had so much coffee
what am i talking about
but um
i think it's helped with some of my
digestion with normally the pasta would
just uh i'd have a hard time with that
and i [ __ ] love pasta gotta be hard
to give up pasta maybe you should go to
tuscany with her i want to let's read
this letter okay but i wouldn't want to
feel like a third view which you would
be yeah okay katie this is from katie
berkey subject would you rather's great
dear justin and christian with it being
women's history month i stumbled across
this list of real life would you
rather's that women face here what
that's so awesome it's in mcsweeney's
and wanted to post some of them to you
for discussion thank you katie what a
great idea okay
and happy women's history man one would
you rather have a career or a family
career or family wow so these are geared
for women is that is that um idea yeah i
don't know but we can answer them we can
answer them and i don't know why it
should i guess now the times have
like right right right change the point
where it really is uh gender neutral it
used to be a decision for you yes it's
not crazy so much has changed yep um for
for me personally i would say
a career family it's hard to answer
because does a family mean like you
can't have a brother
oh i or is that like a kid i didn't mean
like nuclear family
um i would
rather
say it's hard to say i love the idea of
having a family i want a family but i
but you need a career to have the family
not necessarily for them yeah you do you
could just be like uh inherit a bunch of
money all right but what if you don't
have very wealthy relatives
yeah
i think you need you need to have a
career i i i just think it it's i would
pick a career you'd have to i'd have to
i also have no
frame i mean i i don't really have
enough of frame of reference because i
don't have a family of my own i as much
as i'd like one
my career has brought me so much joy and
i it's hard to imagine my life without
that
but of course i can imagine my life
without that out of family because i
don't have them you have me no i know i
i meant like a wife i imagine you me and
you
um number two would you rather be
perceived as likable or competent
uh this is easy for me because i already
because i'm not competent i'm sure i'm
not you i'm definitely you're very
competent at certain times some things
yeah but i'm sure i'm not
well yeah that's that's so it's the
questions would you rather be perceived
as likable or compete oh likeable i
don't care if people think i'm competent
likeable like competence is more
important for me as an individual in
your life but in terms of people knowing
it socially or thinking of me yeah as
competent i don't care that's true i'd
much rather be
seen as competent or uh like yeah wow
freudian uh three would you rather be
told to smile or to calm down
um
smile i know that's the thing that i've
heard that from yeah uh calm down and i
know that that's like a pretty
consistent thing in their lives hear
that yeah um hey cheer up smile you know
i'd rather be so condescending i hate
being told to calm down only because
i usually get
there's usually a need to say that to me
when i'm being like gaslit by something
you know i that's that's something that
triggers me when i when i am not being
heard or
seen in a way you know and so somebody
like doesn't acknowledge what i've said
and i keep having to repeat it or say it
in different ways or impress upon them
an idea and then they say hey calm down
yeah so you you went to a different
place oh really okay but that makes
sense for you yeah
um it is annoying to be told it's a
smile have you ever been told that by a
stranger
i've had that happen where
i'm sure i don't recall
i've also seen guys do that to women
which is gross when when like as a way
to hit on them like
hey baby smile i know you know that yeah
imagine saying that to a stranger it's
crazy i would you i would rather i i
come at it from a slightly different
angle i would rather be told to calm
down
why because i think i aspire to be
um to come across er more jovially
than i do
and i think i'm naturally more
predisposed to being like
kind of uh calm
and so i aspired being that's true to
having more energy and so if someone
tells me to calm down i think that means
that i'm you you're doing more of that
i'm in need of coming yeah yeah so you
would trust them you'd be like oh okay i
will it would be like better advice
right exactly it would be more helpful
advice right
huh those are good smile i can't imagine
someone you've never had i smile you
should smile more
it's like how do you know how i express
i i bet i've heard it i've heard it
here but here's the reason to pick that
one because
telling someone to smile versus or being
told to smile versus being told to calm
down
one is more extreme you know someone's
saying hey you should smile more is it's
such an innocuous thing and it doesn't
make a difference
but someone
if someone tells you to calm down that
means you're that means potentially
you're like making a scene
right and you're um hysterical in some
way by the way something more like
dangerous about well bad options i
should clarify that's not the context
that i was thinking no i know i know i
know but you're right interesting
uh thanks katie those are interesting um
it's and i can understand too just from
to put myself in women's shoes uh
you know that i can understand how
frustrating that must be either one of
those frustrating
um i've never told a woman to smile
neither have i either but i have said
calm down yeah i have yeah
which i'm not proud of
yeah calm down they both are quite
patronizing
and frustrating anyway um thank you
katie for making us see that think
differently about that okay uh thank you
again this is back to katie thank you
again for all that you are doing to keep
us i'm sure she didn't mean thank you
again but i had just said thank you to
her so i felt the need to i think she
meant thank you again yes she did i
think she meant to put the emphasis on
the again yeah not to mansplain during
women's history month i'm just gonna
know what's up emphasis um
thank you again for all that you are
doing to keep us enlightened and
entertained
uh i hope my three boys six three and
seven months are as close to one another
oh as the long boys appear to be as they
get older
oh yeah we're about that ex that's the
same spread yeah it's ours is like um
damian's two
two years older than you and you're
three years older than two and a half
really right you're three like three and
a quarter older than me who cares
okay uh thanksgiving back to katie best
wishes katie b fort myers florida we
were just in your neck of the house oh i
missed it beautiful necklace beautiful
woods
in your neck of the tropical woods um
thanks for that and thanks to everyone
thanks to
rachel john
um everyone uh has been listening wendy
this is a good wrap up so far really oh
great okay i'm gonna just go wait wait
one more thing sorry
yeah well it's important if you guys
want to write into the show our email
address is life is short at
wondering.com that was efficient and i'm
going to make continue with the
efficiency by just wrapping up in a way
that i'm not really prone to doing but
i'm going to do it now because i want to
impress rachel as well
hurry okay
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
life is short is hosted by me justin
long it's co-hosted by you and produced
by you christian law is also produced by
megan monaco as well as senior producer
michelle mieshlands
audio engineer and it gets their hands
on that none other than sergio enriquez
we have executive producer job which
goes to marshall louie and all of us
work for a company that rhymes with
wondering
[Music]
i saw
i was going to give it to you but i
realized that you gave it to me so you
must have it
those little um cds and the white stuff
cds
they were your
your commercials oh oh your dvds yeah
yeah right
in one of the
i don't know which one now the big one i
think
um
you
were a guest of
[Music]
and you dragged your mother around
she she was happy
she likes rachel ray